It's
not like I won physics or anything like that. I was just talking to God about various
things.
Well, we're all here, so let's take a picture, so it's okay to show up properly in this pitch-darkness
.
It's a failure, or rather, it
's better to erase the one with a subtle expression, isn't it?
Let's go, I'll make it
luxurious Hmmm
[music] When
summer comes, let's go to the fireworks together
Wear a yukata
Buy a partition
Let's make interest rates together
No matter how many seasons come and go, I'll hold your hand  Tori
, let's look up at the night sky together again, again and again, on
the surface of the fireworks that bloom in that sky, no matter
how many times,
we're a married couple
.